bien tous merci de me donner la parole
je vous en suis reconnaissant parce
qu'être avec vous ce matin est
aujourd'hui réellement être à ma place à
ma place dans la tra vie politique qui a
toujours été la mienne amarnath poreux
pour dans ce parti qui me fait confiance
pour reconquérir le grand sud ouest
là où je suis né où j'ai grandi et où je
suis aujourd'hui élu à ma place dans un
mouvement qui fait massivement et
courageusement le choix de se
transformer de se réformer de se
décentraliser de se démocratiser de
s'ouvrir au numérique d'inscrire la
parité dans son fonctionnement et de
s'ouvrir à la société française telle
qu'elle est je sais encore peu de la
politique mais assez pour savoir que
l'immobilisme et un reniement
je suis un peu plus de l'entreprise et
du monde économique est là aussi ne pas
anticiper c'est se condamner on oppose
trop souvent les hommes et les femmes
politiques aux hommes et aux femmes de
l'entreprise
pourtant beaucoup nous rassemblons nous
avons la même vision de l'importance de
l'économie
nous avons la même volonté de gestion et
d'efficacité
nous avons la même problématique de
gestion des ressources humaines
nous avons les mêmes besoins de vision
et de stratégie et nous avons le même
souci de l'exécution alors je viens et
je vous rejoins pour construire avec
vous les républicains pour l'axé seine
pour le limousin pour le poitou
charentes et pour la france
merci
vim